(rocket blast)
- What's up Believe Nation?
Today I'm going to talk
about the seven stages
that each start-up goes through
to make their first million dollars.
(hip hop music)
So I get a lot of entrepreneurs
asking me questions
about how to make their
first million dollars.
What are the steps that
companies go through?
What are the stages that
you need to understand
that most businesses flow through?
And so I thought I'd make this video today
sharing my thoughts on the seven steps
that companies go through
on their process to making
their first million dollars.
(upbeat music)
So step number one is you
have to have a dissatisfaction
with the status quo.
You have to not like what's
happening around you.
Successful entrepreneurs
have a big dissatisfaction
with what's currently happening.
They're not happy with the solutions.
They have a problem,
either their own problem
or somebody else's problem,
and they're just not happy
with the current solutions out there.
It's the start of every
single great business.
There has to be a pain
point and a dissatisfaction
with the current solutions out there.
(upbeat music)
Number two is idea generation.
So we have a problem, our own
problem, a friend's problem.
We're dissatisfied with
the solutions out there.
Now, we got to figure out what's an idea
that's going to work.
What's the winning idea that
combines what we love to do,
what we're super passionate, excited about
with what's going to solve the problem?
And there may be multiple
ways to solve this problem.
Whatever problem you're facing right now,
there could be a million
different ways to solve it,
but not all of them are
going to work for you,
and not all of them align with
what you're passionate about.
And so at the core of
every successful business
is a combination of
what there's a need for,
what there's dissatisfaction with,
what pain point people have
with what you are super
passionate and excited about,
and combining those things will lead
to a successful idea to
launch a business with.
(upbeat music)
Stage number three is, you
actually launch your business.
And this is where a lot
of people fall down.
A lot of people get stuck
in just the idea generation,
in the planning, because
it's exciting to plan.
It's exciting to plan
and see how we can build
a multi-million empire and
what our life would look like.
And we get a high from that.
We get a high from thinking
about what our life
could look like, but then we
actually have to do the work.
And doing the work kind of
sucks a lot of the time.
Most of the time.
And we don't want to do that
work cause we want to stay
on that high planet where
we're just imagining
that future vision for ourselves.
You have to start.
So many people have great, amazing ideas
and they see other people
make money off of it
and you claim that that was your idea.
Well, who cares if it was your idea?
They had the idea too,
and they went out and
did something about it.
And so when you have that great idea,
you need to actually start.
Where too many people
die with their best ideas
still in them, you need to
take action on the idea.
(upbeat music)
Stage number four is
failure and adjustment.
A super important thing to
understand is most businesses
don't end up the way that they planned.
The thing that actually makes you money,
that has a big impact,
that helps you explode,
is very rarely the thing
that you start with.
So, it's still important to have a plan.
It's still important to have an idea
of what you're going to do.
But recognizing that that
plan is likely going to fail,
so let's get it out there
as soon as possible.
And then you need to adjust and tweak
to what the market wants and
to what you're passionate about
to build something even better.
It's super important.
Most companies, you look
at how they started.
Look at what their first product was
and look at what they sell now.
It's totally different.
And they had the willingness
to fail and to adjust.
Hewlett-Packard started selling
audio oscillators for films.
And they sold a couple
I don't even know if they
still sell audio oscillators.
It's not anywhere close to being
a big part of their business.
They adjusted.
Wrigley's started off in the
baking soda or baking powder industry,
and as a side they happened
to give some gum away.
So every case that you
bought of their baking soda
or baking powder, you
would get some gum with it.
People really liked the gum so he said,
"Huh, why don't we focus on gum?"
And then Wrigley's became
this big gum brand.
And so part of success in any business
is recognizing that you need
to get through that phase.
That the great idea that you have,
no matter how great it looks in your head,
is not going to be the one that
ultimately guides you to massive success.
It'll be a seed and the
seed will have to grow.
And it'll grow by testing the
idea, by talking to customers,
by getting in the market
and then adjusting.
And too many people make that mistake.
They launch, it doesn't
work, and then they quit.
Expect to launch. Expect it not to work.
And then adjust. Fail and adjust.
That will be your path through.
(upbeat music)
Phase number five is extending the idea.
This is where a lot of
entrepreneurs also will fall down.
They'll have some initial
success with their business.
And now we're talking about the path
to being a million-dollar company.
They'll have some initial
success with their business,
but they won't expand beyond it.
Where it's very rare that
you could take one product
in one single market and
build a million-dollar,
multi-million-dollar company.
You need to start thinking,
how do I expand this?
How do I build to more geographic areas?
How do I expand my product reach?
How do I add more features?
How do I create more services?
How do I add a premium
line or a budget line?
How do I go beyond my state
or my province or my country?
How do I build this thing out?
You need to think about
how am I going to extend
my product line,
and a lot of it will
come from your customers.
Again, this is just adjusting
to what the market wants.
You will find that your
customers will take you places
that you never even thought of.
Again, the success in
business comes from combining
what there's a need for,
what customers want,
and what you're passionate about creating.
So as you get out into the
market, one of the best things
you could do is get as close
to your customers as possible.
It doesn't make financial
sense if you're selling
a $20 product to call each customer
and ask how they're using it.
But it's so important to do
because it's going to give you
the feedback on how you can get better.
How you can improve your product
to better serve their needs,
but also how you can extend
it because the more you
understand their use, the more
you understand their lives,
the more you understand their business,
the more you're going to come
up with other creative solutions
that you can sell into them
and then you can sell to
a broader market, as well.
The way to expand any business,
an easy, fast, simple way to do it
is to talk to every single customer.
Understand why they bought it.
Understand how they're using it.
And then think about you
can expand your market
based on what your customers
need or are asking for
and you have a creative solution for.
(upbeat music)
Number six is building a team.
This is another stumbling block
that a lot of entrepreneurs fall back on.
So you had some success.
You built your first product.
You're getting some results from it.
You're expanding. You're
building other products.
At some point there becomes
a huge crutch on your time.
It's like you can't do more.
Physically.
You just don't have the time.
You're maxed out.
This happens quite early on
for a lot of entrepreneurs.
You're maxed out, and
so to be able to build
the multi-million-dollar company
or getting your first million,
you need to build a team.
You got to bring people on board.
You got to bring on people to help you
get it to the next step.
Even if it starts off part-time.
My first guy was one hour a day.
Started off part-time,
moving up, moving up,
moving up, moving up to
allow you to focus on
the higher picture
things for your business.
Here's what happens in a lot of companies.
You have some success.
You realize you want to build a team.
You hire somebody. Great.
Your first hire doesn't work out.
Usually the first hire won't work out
because you suck as a leader.
You suck as a manager and you
don't know how to hire people.
And that makes sense.
If this is the first time you've done it,
don't expect to bring on a star employee
the first time through.
As you work through that process,
you learn how to be a better manager.
You learn how to be a better leader.
You learn how to improve your process.
So that you bring on better
people to start with.
But what happens to a lot of people
is they didn't get their first hire right.
And then they crouch back and say,
"You know what, I can't
work with other people.
"I just have to do it all myself."
And you can be really successful.
Make a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year
as a solo consultant if
you're one of the best
at what you do in the world.
But you don't see a lot of million-dollar
consultants a year.
There are a few, but solo
million-dollar consultants a year?
You don't really see that happen.
Those guys have a team.
And you need to start to build your team.
If you want to hit a million dollars,
you need to start building
your team to allow you
to focus on the higher leverage things.
And expect to make mistakes
with your first team members.
Expect to hire the wrong people.
Expect them to make mistakes.
And expect for you to work on yourself
to get better as a
leader, manager, recruiter
so you bring the right people on board.
'Cause you need to figure out this piece
if you're going to go off
and accomplish big things.
(upbeat music)
And number seven is leading the team.
So, we've hired our first person.
Now we're going to bring on
more people and more people
and more people and
quickly what you realize
in a bigger company is
your highest leverage skill
is going to be getting
the most out of your team
instead of the productive work that you do
in your business.
So, let me explain.
When you're first starting
off, you're doing everything.
Your value is 100% of the business.
When you hire somebody
new to take on a new role,
you might be both working
the same number of hours,
but you're maybe adding more
value 'cause you're the CEO.
You're the founder.
But let's say it's like
40% them and 60% you.
Or 70% you, 30% them.
Great.
As you add more people, though,
your percentage keeps coming down.
You may be the single most
important person in the business
but collectively your team is
doing way more than you are.
If I look at this business
with this YouTube channel
we've got eight people
working on making this channel
happen for you guys every single day.
I contribute the most value.
Sorry, guys on my team.
But I don't do, like collectively,
my team does way more
than I do 'cause I can't
do all this stuff myself.
And so understanding
that you need to not just
focus on what you are
contributing to the business,
your day-to-day tasks and activities,
but your most important
activity is building up
the people on your team.
'Cause if they get better,
your company gets way,
way, way better.
As you continue to build your team,
your value, in terms of
the tasks you provide,
become decreasingly and
decreasingly important,
because your team takes over
much more of the enterprise.
And so shifting your priorities
to focusing on your team
and building them up
will have a much bigger
impact to help you get to
not just a million dollars,
but way through it, too.
So those are my thoughts
on the seven stages
that start-ups go through
to make their first million.
I'd love to know, what do you guys think?
What point resonated most with you?
What do you need to work on the most
to help you break that barrier?
And am I missing an eight,
nine, ten that you guys
want to add to the list?
Share some love.
I'd love to hear from
you down in the comments
and help the fellow
people of Believe Nation.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.